Die 2. Bundesliga der Männer biegt auf die Zielgeraden ein und das Aufstiegsrennen bleibt weiter extrem eng. Auch der 1. FC Magdeburg und der SC Paderborn mischen immer noch oben mit. Packt einer der Clubs die Sensation? Darüber spreche ich in diesem 2. Liga Schwerpunkt mit Thomas Haufe und Kevin Bublitz. Let's go.
Schon im Programm?
Der Rasenfunk.
Lange ein Fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor.
Und Augsburg ist oben.
Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Bivou. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
So, und ihr kennt das Spiel aus den letzten Wochen, bevor ich mich und die Gäste vorstelle, eine wichtige Durchsage, die Kontoumpfstellung. Es gibt eine extrem wichtige Hausbeteiligung zu Beginn. Die Bankverbindung des Rasenfunk hat sich geändert. Das haben die meisten mitbekommen, aber vielleicht ja manche eben noch nicht. Alle registrierten SupporterInnen haben dazu eine Mail erhalten, die kann allerdings im Spam gelandet sein, wie uns zu Ohren gekommen ist. Guckt da also unbedingt nochmal nach, wenn ihr nichts bekommen habt. Wie gesagt, die Bankverbindung des Rasenfunk hat sich geändert. Ihr müsst bitte jetzt eure Daueraufträge ändern. Es bleiben noch ein paar Tage und dann gibt es das alte Konto nicht mehr und dann führt der Dauerauftrag ins Nichts und dem Rasenfunk bleibt weniger Geld. Das wäre natürlich sehr schade. Ein paar weitere Infos und vor allen Dingen natürlich die neue Kontoverbindung, die findet ihr in den Show Notes. So, zur Sendung. Mein Name ist Marc Schwitzki. Ich führe heute wieder durch diese 2. Liga Sendung der Männer des Rasenfunks und ich bin freier Journalist. Ihr könnt mich lesen bei RBB24 und hören beim HerthaBase Podcast oder eben hier im Wechsel mit Eva. Und ich stelle meinen ersten Gast vor. Wir hatten schon mal die Ehre diese Saison. Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast.
Hallo, Marc.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob es diesmal technisch hält. Aber bislang läuft das wie eine Eins. Ich bin gespannt. Der andere Mann hat sich auch schon oft bewiesen hier im Rasenfunk. Wir haben dieses Mal zum ersten Mal die Ehre, zusammen in einer Folge dabei zu sein. Kevin Bublitz vom Padercast. Grüß dich.
Herzlichen Dank für die Einladung.
Hi. Na, aber. Na, aber. So, bevor wir inhaltlich werden, ihr kennt das Spiel. Wie immer der Hinweis. Sprecht es mir nach. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, Paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich allein durch die Spenden der HörerInnen. Und dementsprechend, wenn ihr dabei sein wollt, dann könnt ihr zum einen den Lebensunterhalt von Max finanzieren, damit er so viel Zeit in dieses ganz tolle Produkt stecken kann. Das Geld wird aber zum Beispiel auch dafür verwendet, dass eben Menschen wie Eva oder ich ihn auch in Sendungen entlassen können und dass die Gäste ein Honorar bekommen. Wenn ihr das unterstützen wollt, dann schaut auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club vorbei und jetzt werden wir sportlich. Wir beginnen mit der Lage der Liga. Wie viel des Spieltags war das jetzt? Der 29. Spieltag der 2. Liga ist vorbei. Ich hatte es schon erwähnt. Die Zielgerade, man biegt darauf ein, 5 Spiele sind es noch. Ich finde, nach dem letzten Spieltag gibt es so ein paar Dynamiken, die sich vielleicht ein bisschen rauskristallisieren. Eine ist, dass sich die Liga endgültig in zwei Teile teilt. Also der Karlsruhe SC spielt ja nur 1-1 gegen Münster. Und bei 5 Spielen sind das insgesamt dann doch 6 Punkte von Rang 3 entfernt. Ich würde die These aufstellen, damit hat man nicht mehr viel zu tun. Hannover auf Platz 9 hingegen hat zwar mit 1-3 gegen Elbersberg verloren zu Hause, ist aber nur 4 Zähler hinter den Saarländern auf Rang 3. Das ist jetzt rechnerisch schon noch möglich, wenn jetzt auch nicht mehr ewig. Total wahrscheinlich, aber es ist noch möglich. Und es scheint, als ob die obere Tabellenhälfte noch um den Aufstieg und die untere gegen den Abstieg spielt. Kevin, Thomas, habt ihr da Gedanken zu? Glaubt ihr, dass es auch vielleicht noch ein paar Vereine nach oben oder unten erwischen könnte, die damit aktuell nicht rechnen? Oder ist das aktuell die klarste Tabellen-Situation, die ihr in der Saison auch so erlebt habt?
Boah, danke. Gerne. Ja, ist eine gute Frage, ob das jetzt die klarste Situation in dieser verrückten Saison ist. Sagt mir irgendwie jedes Jahr, wie verrückt ist die 2. Liga, die stärkste 2. Liga aller Zeiten und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist schon krass, dass das so eng ist. Ich bin bei dir. Hannover ist sicherlich noch im Dunstkreis. Der KSC müsste schon einen heftigen Run haben und die Oben müssten einen heftigen negativen Run haben. Bei den Spielen, die noch da sind, sehr unwahrscheinlich. Ja, aber ansonsten ist da wirklich noch alles drin. Also das ist schon krass. Elversberg springt auf einmal wieder auf Rang 3. Da waren sie schon länger nicht mehr. Und unten bin ich aber relativ sicher, dass, ich glaube, ab– also dass das höchstens noch unter Braunschweig, Münster und Ulm da ausgetauscht wird. Ich glaube, ab Fürth ist das auch zu weit. Also wenn du guckst, Münster bis Fürth sind sieben Punkte. Ist machbar, ja. Und auch Fürth kann mal fünf Spiele noch verlieren. Aber Münster gewinnt halt auch keine fünf Spiele mehr. Das glaube ich nicht. Regensburg vielleicht.
Ja, die sind ganz gut dabei, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Denn es gibt wieder– also was heißt wieder? Es gibt jetzt seit ein paar Wochen, finde ich, wieder mehr Spannung im Abschlusskampf. Da schien ja gewisse Dinge gefühlt schon entschieden zu sein. Dann auch, als sich eben Schalke und Hertha mit ein paar Siegen abgesetzt haben. Aber wenn wir uns das Wochenende jetzt mal angucken. Ulm gewinnt gegen Magdeburg, da werden wir noch drüber reden, Thomas. Regensburg gewinnt gegen Schalke. Klar, Schalke immer für einen Stolperer gut. Und trotzdem, dass Regensburg Spiele gewinnt, ist in der Saison eben noch nicht so oft vorgekommen. Und Münster holt einen Punkt gegen Karlsruhe. Und Braunschweig gewinnt überraschend wie Fulminant mit 4 zu 2 in Hamburg. Und das sind ja alles Ergebnisse, mit denen man jetzt eher nicht gerechnet hat. Also Münster KSC 1-1, okay, das kann man sich vorstellen. Aber alles andere, da sieht man mal, dass dann auch irgendwann angefangen wird, auch unten Punkte geholt zu werden.
Ja, das ist irre. Also, dass wir dann Ulm auch mal so ein Spiel abliefern, das habe ich, ich will nicht sagen erwartet, aber ich habe da schon so ein bisschen, dann war mir das schon klar, nach der wirklich guten Leistung gegen Karsus-Lautern, dass man da jetzt gegen Ulm, dass man da jetzt gegen Ulm wieder patzt. Aber, dass der HSV jetzt dann doch wieder Frühlingsdinge tut, damit habe ich persönlich nicht gerechnet. Ich dachte eigentlich, unter Polizin sind die stabil genug. Aber auch da sieht man ja, Mensch, die sind ja doch auch in der Lage, weiterhin im Februar, oder nicht im Februar, sondern im Frühjahr auszurutschen und alles zu, vielleicht wieder alles zu verspielen, wer weiß. Aber ich sehe es wie Kevin. Unten, glaube ich, ist unter den Mannschaften, die Kevin genannt hat, wird das gemacht. Aber oben, denke ich, wird es noch eine Überraschung geben. Ich glaube, da wird am Ende einer unter den ersten dreien rechnen, mit dem man jetzt landen, mit dem man jetzt vielleicht noch gar nicht rechnet.
Gut möglich auf jeden Fall. Unten, muss man sagen, Regensburg ist jetzt nur noch 6 Punkte, hinter Platz 16. Also es hat schon größere Wunder gegeben.
Aber auch 35 Tore, ja.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist ein extrem wichtiger Punkt, das gewichtet sich natürlich wie ein zusätzlicher oder wie ein weiterer fehlender Punkt an der Stelle. Ulm hat unter Lechleiter so eine zweite Luft bekommen. Das finde ich auch interessant, weil ich denen das nicht zugetraut hätte, weil ich dachte, mit diesem zweimaligen Aufstiegstrainer Wörle würden die schon am Optimum kratzen, so ein Stück weit. Aber man muss ja sagen, unter Lechleiter, wie gesagt, jetzt Magdeburg geschlagen, die letzten Ergebnisse waren nicht verkehrt. Und was ich noch krasser finde, ist, dass sich Braunschweig ohne Trainerwechsel ein neues Momentum gegeben hat. Darin habe ich wirklich nicht mehr geglaubt. Ich hatte ja Braunschweig gegen Hertha gesehen über 90 Minuten. Das 1 zu 5, das war die Solat in allen Bereichen. Und das war so krass, dass selbst auf der PK danach der beteiligte Trainer von sich selber gesagt hat, naja, also aktuell habe ich jetzt nicht mehr so viele Argumente. Und natürlich werden solche Diskussionen geführt. Das klang schon sehr angeschossen. Aber man hat offensichtlich die richtigen Lehren aus diesem Spiel gezogen und sieben Punkte aus den letzten drei Spielen geholt.
Ja, wir bauen gerne solche Mannschaften auf.
Aber Kevin, Moment, Moment, da gehe ich dich rein. Weil das sagt jeder Fan über seinen Verein.
Okay, ich habe aber dann habe ich einen zweiten Punkt.
Okay.
Der Trainer Daniel Scherning, seines Zeichens Paderborner, gebürtiger Paderborner. War zwei Klassen unter mir in der Schule.
Du kennst sie alle, Kevin?
Ja, absolut. Die aus Paderborn. Ich meine, ist ja nicht so groß. Der hat, egal wo er Trainer war, nachdem er nicht mehr Co-Trainer von Steffen Baumgart beim SCP war, hat der noch nie gegen Paderborn verloren. Und als wir da so spielten und die großen Chancen nicht machten und Braunschweig sich dann auf einmal anschickte, Tore zu schießen, dachte ich mir, das gibt es doch nicht, jetzt verliert der wieder nicht. Und tatsächlich hat er das Spiel dann noch gedreht mit der Mannschaft, uns da quasi aus allen Träumen rausgeschossen. Und muss auch schmunzeln, wenn du ihn dann triffst und so. Er weiß glaube ich selber nicht, warum er nie gegen Paderborn verliert. Also er ist wirklich noch ungeschlagen gegen den SCP. Ja, und dann gegen HSV, wenn du das Spiel gesehen hast, was da mit dem HSV los war, war ja auch gar nichts, das war krass. Also Braunschweig hat sehr verdient gewonnen.
Sehr hochverdient, ja.
Vor allem die erste Halbzeit war extrem schlecht vom HSV und in der zweiten haben sie sich ja zumindest angeschickt, Fußball zu spielen, aber waren dann natürlich hinten offen.
Ja, ach so. Bitter für Münster natürlich. Die hatten ja, also sicher waren sie nicht, aber es war schon ein Polster zu Braunschweig, ein gewisses. Und jetzt sind sie halt auf einmal 2 Punkte hinter denen.
Und wie gesagt, Ulm und Regensburg sind auch nicht weg. Also plötzlich geht da wieder alles bei, wie gesagt, fünf Spielen, 15 zu vergebene Punkte. Da kann viel passieren. Viel passieren kann auch nach oben, denn der Spieltag, wir haben es eben schon erwähnt, der HSV verliert gegen Braunschweig. Das ist die erste Niederlage, mein Gott, erste Niederlage nach vier ungeschlagenen Spielen, langsam. Und der restliche Spielplan, Joach Schalke, KSC, Darmstadt, Ulm, Fürth. Sie könnten den Vorteil haben, dass es bis auf Ulm für alle diese Teams um nichts mehr gehen wird. Das ist natürlich nicht verkehrt an der Stelle. Klar, man kann auch sagen, die sind dann befreit und alles. Und trotzdem, glaube ich, ist das eher ein Vor- als Nachteil. Köln hingegen hat eben jetzt ein 1 zu 1 gegen Fürth gespielt und dementsprechend auch seit zwei Spielen nicht mehr gewonnen. Davorher die 0 zu 1 Niederlage gegen Hertha. Und jeweils auch keine sonderlich guten Leistungen, muss man ja auch sagen. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man diese Spiele unerklärlich verloren hätte. Und der restliche Spielplan hat deutlich mehr in sich. Also man spielt jetzt gegen Münster, für die es um alles geht nach wie vor. Hannover, Regensburg, Nürnberg und am letzten spielt der Knallz gegen Kaiserslautern. Also das dürfte nochmal richtig lustig werden. Thomas, was glaubst du denn? Also glaubst du, dass der HSV und Köln, also der HSV hat ja jetzt gerade 5 Punkte Abstand auf Rang 3, Köln 4. Glaubst du, die lassen sich das tatsächlich nochmal nehmen? Oder ist das jetzt ein Schluck aufgewesen und am Ende ziehen sie durch?
Also gut, beim HSV sage ich das auch glaube ich schon seit 3 oder 4 Jahren. Aber ich glaube, dieses Jahr sind sie dann wirklich mal dran. Ich glaube, Hamburg lässt sich das nicht mehr nehmen. Also ich glaube, die sind unter Polizin stabil genug, solche Ausrutscher wie jetzt auch gegen Braunschweig wieder zu korrigieren. Da denke ich, dass die aufsteigen werden. Bei Köln bin ich mir da noch nicht so sicher. Ich habe die letzten Spiele, also nicht in Gänze, aber teilweise gesehen können. Gegen Viert hat man ein bisschen Pech gehabt. Ich fand schon, da war man gut im Spiel. Gab es auch am Ende, hätte man nach Köln einen klaren Durchmeter bekommen müssen, den man nicht gegeben hat. Dann hat man aber auch Glück gehabt vorher, dass das Viert für mich ein reguläres Tor aberkannt bekommen hat. Aber die wirken mir nicht so gefestigt. Ich finde, Hamburg wirkte in den Spielen einfach gefestigt. Wenn man jetzt mal Braunschweig außen vor lässt, ich habe die ja bei uns gesehen, das war beeindruckend. Also die erste halbe Stunde hätten die ohne Torwart gegen uns spielen können. Wir waren ja nicht einmal in der Gegner-Schneidhälfte. Ich glaube schon, dass Hamburg hochgeht. Bei Köln bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Ich glaube, Elbersberg hat jetzt ein bisschen das Momentum auf seiner Seite. Die haben, auch wenn die jetzt nur unentschieden gespielt haben, gewonnen.
Die haben nach Rückstand noch 3-2 in Hannover gewonnen.
So war es genau. Die hatten letzte Woche auch gegen Regensburg sehr deutlich gewonnen mit 6-0. Die haben jetzt ein bisschen dieses Momentum auf ihrer Seite, was man glaube ich in dieser Phase auch braucht. Mein Geheimfavorit ist und bleibt aber Düsseldorf tatsächlich. Ich glaube, die werden am Ende noch unter die ersten 3 springen. Mal gucken, wozu wir noch in der Lage sind. So eine Wundertüte. Eigentlich alle da oben. SCP war ja auch wieder... Für mich waren die eigentlich, nachdem sie jetzt bevor sie die 2 Spiele verloren haben, war Paderborn für mich eigentlich der Favorit auf Platz 3. Jetzt verlieren die gegen Braunschweig und gegen...
Du kannst sie lieber nicht tippen.
Es ist auch ein bisschen...
Aber ja, ich fand, wie gesagt, bei Köln, da würde ich mitgehen. Ich glaube auch, dass der HSV hochgehen wird, auch weil Robert Latzel kann immer noch immer mehr ein Faktor jetzt werden, nachdem er zurück ist. Der ist ja noch gar nicht richtig dabei, hat trotzdem schon wieder ein Tor gemacht. Aber ich glaube, ich glaube auch, dass es jetzt ein Ausrutscher war. Ich halte sehr viel von dem Fußballunterpolzin. Köln hingegen, ich muss mal wirklich sagen, ich habe jetzt nicht 20 Spiele von denen diese Saison gesehen, aber ein paar schon und ich fand nicht eins richtig gut. Das ist dann auch wieder eine Qualität von so vielen, dann auch so viele zu gewinnen. Aber ich hatte ja auch schon hier mit Dennis aus dem Trotzdem-Hier-Podcast gesprochen, der als Kölner auch sagt, ja, die Ergebnisse stimmen, aber Euphorie macht sich nicht breit. Und auch keine Gelassenheit, was die Aufstiegsplätze angeht. Weil was ist, wenn man diese engen Spiele nicht mehr zieht? Und das passiert jetzt eben. Und ich also ja, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist immer noch höher, dass sie es schaffen als das, dass sie es nicht schaffen. Und trotzdem würde ich jetzt nicht mehr aus allen Wolken fallen, wenn sie von den letzten Spielen, ich habe ja die Gegner aufgezählt, nicht so viele gewinnen. Kevin, was ist denn da dein Bauchgefühl?
Also ich habe sie ja jetzt letztens erst in Paderborn gesehen, wo sie auch gewonnen haben, was ich mir nicht ganz erklärt habe. Also das war ja bei uns so der Anfang vom Abfall. Waren wir eigentlich auch die Mannschaft mit den besseren Chancen, haben 2 richtig Duseltore gefangen, einmal wo Götze den Ball hinten am Kopf kriegt, der dann ins Tor zurückgeht. Und das zweite Ding war auch, also die Kölner konnten sich wirklich glücklich schätzen, dass sie da 3 Punkte geholt haben. Ein Punkt, okay, aber das ist halt durch die individuelle Klasse immer drin bei denen. Aber sie hätten das auch verlieren können. Für einen SCP war das so der Startschuss. Für Köln war das wirklich glücklich, aber du siehst ja auch schon 43 Tore erst geschossen, im Vergleich zu den anderen, die da oben stehen. Aber natürlich auch nur 34 kassiert. Das ist so ein bisschen, wie du gerade gesagt hast, sie haben die knappen Spiele oft gezogen, mit einem Torunterschied irgendwie. Es sind 4 Punkte, auf Elbersberg, auf Düsseldorf. Das kannst du bei den Gegnern gut noch vergeigen. Beim HSV bin ich mir auch relativ sicher, dass die 3 der 5 Spiele auf jeden Fall noch gewinnen werden. Und dann sind die endlich wieder in der Bundesliga.
Drei von drei sind sie sicher, dass die hochgehen. Oh mein Gott, werden die in der Liga bleiben. Jetzt haben wir es gejinkst, glaube ich.
Kleine Anekdote dazu. Mein bester Freund ist HSV-Fan. Und er hat tatsächlich gegen Braunschweig das Ergebnis richtig getippt. Also er hatte tatsächlich auf 2 zu 4 gegen Braunschweig getippt, weil er meinte, die gegen Braunschweig verliehenden wir immer mindestens ein Spiel. Also mindestens. Eigentlich immer beide. Das ist ganz komisch, so wie das bei uns gegen Führer zum Beispiel ist. Aber ich glaube, die sind so stark 63 zu 36 Tore. Sie können halt mal eben so ein Spiel, wie Thomas gesagt hat, da siehst du eine halbe Stunde die anderen Mannschaften gar nicht agieren. Also aus einem eigenen Strafraum irgendwie. Ich glaube, das machen die doch gar nicht. Und da drunter ist Roulette. Düsseldorf, ganz ehrlich. Wie die hier gewonnen haben, weiß Danny Tune auch nicht.
Aber das ist auch eine Fähigkeit von deine Tune-Mannschaften.
Mit elf verletzten Spielern haben die hier angetreten, haben den ersten Torschuss nach 40 Minuten oder so was gehabt, gefühlt. Und der war dann auch gleich drin. Unfassbar, wie das geworden ist. Die waren in allen Belangen sowas von unterlegen. Und ich habe keinen einzigen fußballerischen Ansatz dort gesehen, außer hinten drin zu stehen und das Ding rauszuköpfen.
Ich habe beide Spiele gegen Hertha gesehen. Und da sind auch beide Siege von Düsseldorf genauso gekommen. Besonders im Spiel. Hertha hat die komplett bespielt. Und dann hat Düsseldorf zwei Standards reingemacht und hat das Ding gezogen.
Ja, ich hatte auch vor dem Spiel...
Auf eine gute Qualität.
Das ist Fußball.
Naja, ich habe die Kollegen von Gebrabel Rot-Weiß von dem Fortuna-Podcast hier vorm Spiel getroffen in Paderborn am Wochenende. Und die haben auch gesagt, das ist halt momentan unser Spielansatz. Das geht momentan nicht an. Sie haben halt echt wichtige Spieler verloren. Aber ich bin bei euch. Thomas, du hast es, glaube ich, gesagt. Sie haben gerade so ein Momentum. Das sind so ein kleiner Geheimfavorit. Geheimtipp, meine ich. Weil die sind da hochgekommen, das hätte ich nicht mehr gedacht. Also als die auf Platz 10 oder wo standen. Aber ich habe gedacht, du warst.
Ja, genau.
Und jetzt sind sie auf Platz 4. Ja, und darunter FCM. Verliert die wichtigen Spiele irgendwie auch immer. Das ist so unfassbar.
Da werden wir jetzt drüber reden. Wollen wir direkt rübergehen? Machen wir das doch mal. Sehr schön. Alles klar. Dann gehen wir nämlich aus der Lage der Liga zu den Lagen der jeweiligen Vereine. Wir starten rein aus tabellarischen Gründen. Ich habe es im Vorgespräch schon gesagt, der eine Punkt hat den Unterschied gemacht. Wir starten mit dem 1. FC Magdeburg. Thomas, am vergangenen Samstag hat es eben die jetzt schon besagte 0 zu 1 Niederlage bei Abschließkandidat Ulm gegeben. Was ist denn in dem Spiel schiefgelaufen?
Alles.
Also 0 zu 1 ist doch okay.
Ja, aber es war wirklich, also es war, das Spiel ging los und man hatte sofort, also wie beschreibe ich das? Also ich hatte von Anfang an das Gefühl, oh, für Ulm, du siehst genau, bei Ulm, für die geht es um alles. Das ist so ein bisschen so nach dem Sieg von Braunschweig, mussten die ja gewinnen, um dran zu bleiben und ja, die kamen raus und hatten die erste Viertelstunde wirklich mehr auf vom Spiel. Ich hatte eigentlich gedacht, Mensch, Qualität hat man ja gesehen, also vorne 28 Tore vorher in 28 Spielen, aber auch nur 35 Gegentore als Tabell in 17. Da ist für mich eigentlich klar gewesen, okay, die wählen auch erstmal diesen defensiven Ansatz, fand aber, die haben uns die erste Viertelstunde ordentlich bespielt. Jetzt mit ihren Mitteln, also es war jetzt nicht, dass sie uns jetzt komplett reingedrängt haben, aber ich fand schon, dass die Umschaltsituationen diese hatten und auch die Kontersituationen, die sie gespielt haben, die waren nicht schlecht. Und das 1 zu 0 fällt ja dann auch aus dem Ballverlust von Elzay in den Mittelfeld, wo sie dann gut umschalten, wo sie die Seite gut verlagern, den Ball dann wieder in den 16er spielen. Der Torschütze steht dann eben da sehr, sehr gut, macht das 1 zu 0. Und dann war es ein Spiel, wie man es dann wirklich erwarten konnte. Ulm hat hinten einfach sehr, sehr sicher gestanden. Das muss man schon sagen, wenig zugelassen. Ich glaube, wir hatten in 90 Minuten drei Torschüsse. Der Gefährlichste davon war tatsächlich in der 88. Also, die haben defensiv verdammt gut gestanden. Wir haben wirklich alle unsere Stärken, die wir haben, aus dem Spiel genommen. Und ja, dann wird es eben auch gegen eine Mannschaft wie Ulm schwer, die dann sich dann in jeden Zweikampf reinhaut und dann mit relativ einfachen Mitteln, aber mit vollkommen legitimen Mitteln dann eben diese drei Punkte dann am Ende für mich auch völlig verdient geholt hat.
Man spricht da eben auch von der drittbesten Defensive der Liga. Das muss man sagen, das ist ihr großes Brett in dieser Saison. Was mich bewundert hat, ich habe mir die Ergebnisse der Saison angeguckt und Magdeburg ist zwar oben mit dabei, kann aber in den Ergebnissen keine richtige Konstanz aufbauen, sonst wäre man sehr wahrscheinlich auch in den Sphären von HSV und Köln, aber nach dem 17. und 18. Spieltag gab es keine zwei Siege in Folge mehr. Das fand ich irgendwie, das nimmt man anders wahr, so von außen. Woran liegt das denn deiner Meinung?
Das ist, glaube ich, die 1 Mio. Euro-Frage oder die 6 fehlenden Punkte-Frage. Habe ich sie gefunden. Ja, wir können es uns auch nicht erklären. Wir diskutieren uns im Podcast auch immer hoch und runter, woran es liegt, dass du Spiele hast, jetzt wie gegen Kaiserslautern, wo du wirklich deren Stärken komplett aus dem Spiel nimmst. Ich meine, bei Laotern kommt viel über Zweikampfhärte, über gutes Umschaltspiel und das weiß man ja alles. Das haben sie super im Griff gehabt gegen Kaiserslautern. Da dachte ich, was ist denn hier los? Ja, schlagen die völlig verdient mit 2 zu 0. Die hätten ja noch 10 Stunden spielen können, die haben im Spiel keinen Tor geschossen. Und dann fährst du nach Ulm und denkst dir so, Mensch, jetzt hast du eine Riesenchance. Du fährst jetzt zum 17., hast dann den 18. zu Hause. Kannst du jetzt also, ich sag mal, vielleicht von 4 bis 6 Punkten ein Stück weit ausgehen, kannst dich da oben wirklich festbeißen. Und dann verlierst du in Ulm und wir wissen es auch nicht. Weil die Leistung der Mannschaft oder auch die ganze Art und Weise der Mannschaft im Vergleich zum Kaiserslautern-Spiel, war das eine 180-Grad-Drehung. Alles, was gegen Kaiserslautern richtig gut war, was da war, war in Ulm einfach nicht da. Woran das liegt, keine Ahnung. Ich frage mich das auch. Der Trainer fragt sich das wahrscheinlich auch, weil sonst würde es halt nicht passieren.
Ja, zumindest in der Heimtabelle hat man sich ja verbessern können. Nehmen wir mal das Positive. Also, zwischenzeitlich hat man ja ein komplettes Jahr auf dem Heimseeg gewartet, war zwischenzeitlich dann trotzdem Tabellenerster. Die geht nur in der zweiten Liga. Wie ist es denn gelungen, zu Hause dann ja erst gegen Köln mit 3 zu 0 zu gewinnen? Das war der 22. Spieltag. Und dann ja auch aus den nächsten drei Heimauftritten zwei zu holen. Also ist das so ein klassischer Fall von Knoten geplatzt oder hat man irgendwas verändert? Kannst du dir das irgendwie erklären?
Ich glaube, das war wirklich ein klassischer Fall von Knoten geplatzt gegen Köln. Köln war ja lange ein 0 zu 0 Spiel, finde ich. Wenn man den Spielverlauf sieht, das war wirklich so ein Spiel, wo du sagen konntest, okay, wer da das erste Tor schießt, der wird als Sieger vom Platz gehen. So war es ja dann auch. Da kam uns ein Stück weit natürlich auch zu Gute, dass das für Köln das vierte Spiel innerhalb von zwölf Tagen war. Das tat uns, glaube ich, ganz gut, der Sieg. Nur leider ist dann so ein bisschen– das heißt leider, ich meine, das ist immer noch jammernd, auf sehr hohem Niveau– aber es ist uns ein bisschen dann diese Aussatzstärke flöten gegangen, nachdem wir dann angefangen haben, zu Hause zu gewinnen. Ich glaube, seitdem haben wir keinen Aussatzspieler gewonnen. Man kann ja nicht alles haben. Aber das ist natürlich ein Auswandpunkt. Im Prinzip hast du dich ja dann nicht wirklich verbessert. Also du holst ja die Punkte, die du vorher ausgescrollt hast, du holst sie dann jetzt zum Glück auch zu Hause. Das ist natürlich für die Heimzuschauer auch schön, mal Heimsiege zu sehen. Aber grundsätzlich, ich würde sagen, es ist einfach Knoten geplatzt. Und dann war es gut, dass wir dann mal wieder gewonnen haben zu Hause.
Das ist ja so eine Kopfsache am Ende. Apropos Kopfsache, wie erlebst du denn die Mannschaft und das Trainerteam aktuell? Also hat man das Gefühl, dass sie sich so ein bisschen vom Hype anstecken lassen? Spüren sie vielleicht sogar Druck? Mit so was kann ja auch so eine Niederlage in Ulm irgendwie erklärt werden. Oder hast du das Gefühl, die bleiben eigentlich recht fokussiert?
Also ich glaube, Christian Thies bleibt da schon bei sich. Ich glaube nicht, dass er da irgendwie auch Druck reinbringt. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich kann mir aber schon vorstellen, dass in der Mannschaft für einige Spieler wahrscheinlich auch die einzige Chance ist, noch einmal in die Bundesliga zu kommen. Ich denke, wenn man zum Beispiel an den Baris Atik denkt, der ist inzwischen auch schon 30. Ich glaube, es ist für ihn vielleicht auch wirklich so die letzte Chance, in die 1. Bundesliga aufzusteigen. Matthiesen, der 29, ist wahrscheinlich auch. Da sind schon auch ein paar Spieler dabei, für die das wahrscheinlich auch eine einmalige Geschichte wäre. Da brauchen wir glaube ich nicht drüber reden, ob sie jetzt alle Bundesliga-Qualität haben. In dem Sinne, das baue ich mal zu bezweifeln. Aber die Chance ist immer noch da und ich glaube schon, dass da bei den Spielern jetzt auch so ein kleines bisschen der Kopf ins Spiel kommt. Und wenn man dann wie in Ulm gegen eine Mannschaft spielt, für die es halt auch noch um alles geht und die halt genau weiß, wir müssen hier heute eigentlich irgendwie gewinnen. Und wenn du dann, ich sage mal, vor Minute eins diesen Schalter halt auch vielleicht nicht umlegen kannst, wenn du denkst, naja, wir machen hier weiter unser Spiel. Und das ist ja auch so etwas, was sich auch durch diese Saison zieht. Bei aller Euphorie, die hier zu Recht entstanden ist, auch aufgrund vieler guten und sehr guten Spiele, glaube ich aber auch, muss man einfach sagen, wenn dann mal diese Spiele, die du so nicht trägst, dann sind wir halt leider auch nicht in der Lage, mal was zu verändern. Gegen Kaiserslautern war halt sehr auffällig, dass mit Al Holmström auch mal ein Stürmer im Spiel war, der mal andere Facetten reinbringt. Einfach mal mit Rücken zum Tor agiert, ein bisschen fruchtiger, ist groß, dass man Spieler binden kann, auch im 1 gegen 1, einfach im körperlichen Bereich auch mal gegenhalten kann. Das hat uns gegen Ulm schon massiv gefehlt. Man sieht, was da für Kanten hinten drin standen. Da sind natürlich Bordschuhe und Cars körperlich einfach abgemeldet. Das muss man einfach so sagen. Das war schon ein großer Effekt. Der hat uns natürlich aufgrund der Verletzung von Holmström jetzt in Ulm wieder gefehlt. Mal gucken, wie lange der noch ausfällt. Das wird wohl ein muskelfaseres. Das wird wahrscheinlich definitiv noch eine Woche, wenn nicht sogar länger ausfallen. Das muss man dann sehen. Aber ich denke schon, dass bei den Spielern so ein bisschen jetzt auch das Grübeln kommt. Mensch, wir können ja wirklich richtig was erreichen.
Das sei auch irgendwie am Ende des Tages die Krux vielleicht an einem Trainer wie Christian Titz, der auf der einen Seite seine Spiele, die er fast schon perfektioniert hat. Und deswegen ja, wenn der Plan A funktioniert, man denkt, wie kann der 1. FC Magdeburg so einen Fußball spielen? Aber er ist dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerade der Trainer der pragmatischen Sorte, der dann auch mal easy sagt, naja gut, dann halt Plan B.
Nee, das sieht man ja auch regelmäßig. Also wenn man das sieht gegen HSV, haben wir lange versucht, den Spielstil zu spielen, den wir da versucht haben. Wir haben verloren. Dann das Spiel in Hannover war ja genauso ein Spiel, wo Hannover dann mit relativ einfachen Mitteln uns offensiv gut abmählen konnte. Es kommt ja auch nicht von ungefähr, dass wir in den letzten 4 Spielen 3-mal vorne zu Null gespielt haben. Das hat ja auch Gründe und ich glaube einfach, dass sich Mannschaften ganz gut drauf eingestellt haben. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, also entweder musst du uns wirklich richtig früh stören, also wirklich erste Presselinie gleich drauf und Druck ausüben, so wie es der HSV gemacht hat.
Ja.
Oder wie Hannover es gemacht hat, relativ tief stehen und uns im Mittelfeld die Räume dann auch geben, aber dann so 20, 25, 30 Meter vor dem Tor dann einfach sehr, sehr kompakt stehen. Dann macht man es uns auch schwer, wenn man es aber so macht wie Kase Laudon zum Beispiel, dass man uns diese Räume eben gibt, die wir brauchen, dann weiß man, dass diese Mannschaft in der Lage wirklich jeden aus dem Stadion zu ballern. Das ist einfach so. Also wenn das dann mal läuft, das hat man ja gerade zu Beginn der Hinrunde gesehen. Ich meine Ende der Rückrunde oder Ende der Hinrunde 5 zu 2 in Düsseldorf gewinnst du mal nicht einfach so. Dann haben wir Schalke 5-2 aus dem eigenen Stadion gehauen, in Elbersberg 5-2 gewonnen. Also das macht man ja nicht einfach so. Da muss man ja schon auch ein bisschen was auf dem Kasten haben. Und das hat die Mannschaft einfach drauf. Aber wenn dann Plan A so ein bisschen ins Wackeln gerät, sind wir halt nicht in der Lage, auch Spieler auf dem Rasen nicht dann mal was zu ändern. Also das ist dann wirklich, da wird dann weiter Versuch Plan A. Und dann hast du eben so ein Spiel wie in Ulm.
Das Restprogramm ist ja wirklich kein einfacher Endspurt, wie ich finde. Also spielst du jetzt gegen Regensburg, Hertha, Münster, Paderborn. Würde ich auch dich gerne gleich reinholen, Kevin. Über die Partie müssen wir natürlich noch mal reden. Und Düsseldorf am letzten Spieltag, das hat Zunder. Was ist denn da dein Bauchgefühl? Also bleibt Magdeburg bis zum Ende dieser Verlosung und auch stieg mit drin. Aktuell trennen den FCM ja drei Punkte andersrum. Ein Punkt von Rang 3 und 5 von Rang 2. So rum. Wie ist da deine Perspektive?
Also ich glaube schon, dass wir bis zum Ende dabei bleiben, weil da oben einfach keine Konstanz ist. Also bis auf den HSV vielleicht. Aber ich glaube, wenn es um Platz 3 geht, Platz 2 muss man sehen, wie das bei Köln jetzt läuft. Aber ich glaube schon, um Platz 3 bleiben wir bis zum Ende mit drin in der Verlosung, weil einfach da oben die Inkonstanz, die größte Konstanz ist. Das ist unglaublich, wie schwach konstant die Mannschaften da oben alle sind. Also wie gesagt, Beispiel zum Beispiel, also wir können mich nehmen oder auch Kevins SCP kann man auch nehmen. Die gewinnen drei Spiele oder vier Spiele in Folge. Da denkst du wieder, oh jetzt sind sie dran und dann verlieren sie wieder drei Spiele, wo du denkst, meine Güte und das gegen Mannschaften, wo du sagst, das sind eigentlich Gegner, die müssten der SCP locker im Griff haben. Und das ist eben, das zieht sich ja bei allen durch. Das ist bei uns so, das ist bei Paderborn so, das ist bei Düsseldorf so. Elbersberg war ja auch phasenweise weg. Die waren ja auch schon neun, damit ich glaube, sieben oder sechs Punkten Rückstand auf den ersten drei Plätze. Und jetzt sind die da auf einmal wieder auf Platz drei. Also ich glaube schon, dass wir da oben damit dabei bleiben, was aber dann auch eher daran liegt, dass da oben scheinbar auch keiner wirklich weg will. Also wir wollen ja alle weiter bis zum Ende irgendwie Spannung haben, offensichtlich.
Kevin, wenn du hörst, was gegen Magdeburg funktioniert und nicht funktioniert, wie schätzt du da denn das vorletzte Spiel der Saison ein?
Thomas wird es wissen. Wir haben erst einmal gegen Magdeburg gewinnen können. Es gab neun Unentschieden und vier Niederlagen.
Wow.
Ich weiß nicht. Also es riecht nach einem Unentschieden.
Ja, ja. Ich glaube, bei euch wären wir wieder 0-0-Spiel oder 1-1.
Wir hatten in der dritten Liga damals wilde Duelle, als wir noch Steffen Baumwert dabei hatten. Und seitdem ist das so ein bisschen verflacht.
Aber ich finde, die Spiele gegen Paderborn sind eigentlich immer, gerade in den letzten zwei Jahren, für mich immer wirklich Trainertuelle. Ich finde, Christian Titz und Lukas Kwasniok versuchen, sich gegenseitig auszustechen mit Ideen. Ich fand vor allem das letzte Spiel in Paderborn, wo wir 0-0 gespielt haben, war für mich ein Paradebeispiel. Paderborn war in der Anfangsphase klar überlegen, er spielte sich auch Möglichkeiten, macht aber das Tor nicht. Und irgendwann haben sich beide Mannschaften so dermaßen neutralisiert, dass es klar war, das Ding geht nur 0-0 aus. Das ist in den letzten Spielen immer so. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, Kevin, wann hat das letzte Mal einer von uns gewonnen? Das ist auch locker zwei Jahre her. Also, ich weiß nicht, letzte Hinrunde bei uns unentschieden, letzte Saison bei euch unentschieden. Ich glaube, da hatten wir zu Hause gegen euch auch.
2022 haben wir.
Also, es ist schon ein bisschen her, dass ich da mal einen Sieg gehabt habe.
1-0.
Das ist schon ganz interessant. Ich finde, das ist halt auch immer spannend, gerade so die Trainer-Duelle dann auch zu sehen. Titz-Kwasniok, was die dann aus diesem Spiel so machen, das ist immer wieder fast, ja.
Also, du hast vollkommen recht. Also, es gab das höchste, der Gefühl war immer ein 1-1. Mehr Tore sind nie gefallen als zwei. Und dann aber auch auf jeder Seite maximal nur eins. Immer. Ja. Das letzte Spektakel war das 4-4-Jahr 2018.
Oh ja, das war schön.
Also, ja, du hast gefragt, wie optimistisch bin ich in dem Duell oder für das Duell. Wir spielen zu Hause. Magdeburg spielt auswärts eigentlich diese Saison ziemlich stark. Und das kann echt der absolute Game-Changer im Rennen um Platz 3. Dann wird es wahrscheinlich sein, weil ich bin auch bei Thomas. Ich glaube nicht, dass einer da sich jetzt noch absetzen wird. Das wird, glaube ich, wirklich bis zum letzten Spieltag am letzten Spieltag so ein Herzschlagfinale geben, wo man dann guckt, 75. Minute Tor in irgendwo und dann 78. Tor in so und oh.
Und dann ist irgendwo wieder der Empfang schlecht und jemand glaubt schon, die Relegation sicher zu haben und dann jetzt ausfällt und nein, es wird noch gespielt.
Genau, es gibt irgendwo dann 10 Minuten Nachspielzeit.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und in der neunten Minute der Nachspielzeit fällt dort dann das Tor.
Es ist nicht so lange her, dass so was erlebt wurde, aber wir wollen hier nicht alte Wunden aufreißen in Hamburg. Magdeburg hat noch nie in der ersten Liga gespielt, wie wir sie heute kennen. So also das wäre ja was unglaubliches für diesen Verein. Glaubst du denn, dass Verein und Mannschaft überhaupt so weit sind, im Oberhaus irgendwie mitteilen zu können? Also man sagt ja auch, ein Aufstieg kommt nie zur falschen Zeit, weil es ist ein Aufstieg und das muss man mitnehmen. Aber was wäre denn in der Stadt los, wenn das gelingen würde? Und was glaubst du, wie man sich denn in der ersten Liga behaupten würde?
Also ich glaube schon, dass das ja schon ein Ausnahmezustand wäre, wenn man tatsächlich in die Bundesliga aufsteigt, weil das ist ja schon, gab es noch nie, hast du es gesagt, im gesamten deutschen Fußball wäre das das erste Mal. Und es ist einfach auch eine Riesenchance. Diese Saison ist eine Riesenchance, das tatsächlich zu schaffen. Von daher wünsche ich mir einfach, dass die Mannschaft die auch hundertprozentig nutzen will und der Verein auch und ob man soweit ist. Also es gibt Stimmen auch in meinem Umfeld, die sagen, das käme eigentlich zu früh, weil wir von der Entwicklung nicht weit genug sind. Ich sage mir, alleine schon aufgrund der TV-Gelder, musst du eigentlich diese Chance nutzen wollen, weil du glaube ich viele Dinge, die du finanziell auch anschiebst, gerade im Umfeld, sei es Trainingsbedingungen etc., die ja bei uns wirklich, da muss ja wirklich was gemacht werden. Und du könntest da...
Lass mich da gerne mal, das ist ein total wichtiger Punkt, aber da würde ich Kevin reinholen, weil ihr habt das ja jetzt zweimal erlebt mit Paderborn. Funktioniert das nachhaltig, dieses eine Erstliga, ja, dass das Dinge anschiebt?
Ich finde schon.
Wenn du es investiert hast, gut investierst, absolut. Und zwar nicht in Beine, sondern in Steine, wie man mal so schön sagt. Wir haben komplett unseren Unterbau damit hochgebaut. Also wirklich aufgebaut, Trainingszentrum neu. Klar, da hat die Stadt auch was dazugegeben und so weiter und so fort. Aber trotzdem in den Strukturen. Wir haben, glaube ich, in jeder, ich will mich nicht vertun, aber soweit ich es weiß, kriegt bei uns jeder U-Trainer einen Festgehalt. Oder zumindest in irgendeiner Form gehalten, was nicht bei allen Vereinen, auch bei anderen Profi-Vereinen nicht der Fall ist. Wir haben die Regionalliga-Mannschaft inzwischen. Das war ein großer Wurf, der uns gelungen ist, denn das hat uns immer gefehlt, damit unsere Nachzügler, die Talente, überhaupt eine annähernd relevante Spielpraxis haben, in einer Spielklasse, die auch relevant ist. Weil davor sind alle nach Ferl ausgeliehen worden oder sonst wohin.
Und das hat ja sogar schon Spieler in die Profimannschaft gespielt, oder?
Ja, Ron Schallenberg zum Beispiel war jetzt der Letzte, der dann halt jetzt auf Schalke inzwischen ist. Und einige weitere. Oder Schonlau, der beim HSV inzwischen ist, Kapitän ist. Das sind ja alles Eigengewächse, Lucas Kruse damals. Und das ist halt wirklich maßgeblich nur möglich gewesen, weil wir diese Gelder aus den Erstliga-Jahren mitgenommen haben. Beim ersten Mal ist natürlich echt was schiefgegangen mit dem Komplettabsturz, fast in die vierte Liga. Aber trotzdem hat man zwei Dinge mitgenommen, Infrastruktur investiert und zwar klug und nicht einfach rausgeballert, sondern klug investiert.
Das Werk von Ralf Huschen, der mittlerweile bei Hertha ist.
Ja, und von Markus Krösche vor allem, der bei Amtsantritt sagte, wir müssen hier aus diesem netten, kleinen örtlichen, regionalen Vereinen ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen machen. Wir müssen denken, wir sind ein wirtschaftlich denkendes Unternehmen. Und wir brauchen eine Philosophie, die von den Profis– das ist jetzt nicht neu, das kennen wir von Barcelona früher im Hype auch– von Profis bis unter die gleichen Systeme spielt und die gleichen Ansatz hat. Und wir dürfen uns nie wieder abhängig machen von einem Trainer, der dann das und das und das haben will. Sondern der Trainer wird für diese Philosophie geholt und eingesetzt. Und nicht nur der Trainer oben, sondern auch die Trainer drunter in den Nachwuchsetagen. Deswegen bin ich bei Thomas. Das wäre, glaube ich, ein maßgeblich riesiger Schritt für einen FCM, wenn man überlegt, wo sie die letzten Jahre so sich aufgehalten haben. Ich glaube auch, dass es sehr schnell gehen würde. Aber wir haben damals auch den Durchmarsch von der 3. Liga in die 1. gemacht. Wenn du danach es schaffst, dich klug zu konsolidieren und nicht rumspinst, ja, wir müssen direkt wieder oben mitspielen in der 2. Liga, wenn wir abgestiegen sind, sondern dann wirklich zwei Jahre Ruhe walten lässt und auch einen Trainer machen lässt und Vertrauen hast in das Team und nicht irgendwelche Altstars irgendwo herholst, weil du denkst, okay, die haben jetzt die riesen Erfahrungen, und die müssen wir jetzt nehmen, damit wir wieder…
Ich weiß nicht, von wem du redest.
Ja, wir haben in Paderborn auch den Fehler damals gemacht, beim ersten Mal. Das ist einfach so. Ja, ich weiß, in Berlin und Schalke und überall, es waren viele Vereine, die machen den Fehler. Bielefeld hatten auch zuletzt gemacht, ist runtergesaust. Das ist ja auch verlockend, sich den möglichst einfachsten Weg zu wählen mit gestandenen Profis, die aber vielleicht halt dann auch nicht so die Identifikation haben, satt sind, nicht so gierig sind. Jetzt habe ich lange gequatscht, auf jeden Fall, vom finanziellen Aspekt her ist es einfach unvergleichbar mit der 2. Liga. Was du da für Möglichkeiten hast, durch ein Jahr alleine schon. Der SCP hat keine Schulden mehr danach gehabt. Wir sind schuldenfrei.
Schulden haben wir sowieso nicht. Aber grundsätzlich ist es ja schon so, wie Kevin sagt. Ich glaube, der SCP ist da ja für uns auch, für mich zumindest, für mich persönlich, aus dem, was man ja auch aus langen Jahren gemeinsamen Podcasten so ein bisschen erfahren hat, ist ja Paderborn auch so ein Stück weit, kann man ja schon so ein kleines Vorbild.
Also, man ruft dir denn hier endlich die Freundschaft aus.
Das ist ja schon längst, das haben wir doch schon längst.
Man hat schon so viele Spiele aus Magdeburg bekommen.
Genau, genau.
Nur der FCM und Paderkass-Schal, das sag ich doch mal nach.
Und ja, also von daher ist das ja schon, und du würdest einfach alleine in der finanziellen Entwicklung locker drei Jahre überspringen. Und wie Kevin schon sagt, wenn man das dann clever einsetzt und eben auch ganz klar sagt, wir nehmen ja auch sofort den Widerabstieg, ohne da auch nur im Ansatz mal den Trainern Frage zu stellen, absolut in Kauf. Und dann glaube ich schon, dann wäre das auch, wenn man dann wirklich gesponnen jetzt mal aufsteigt und dann im Jahr drauf gleich wieder absteigt, mein Gott, dann wäre es halt so. Und ich glaube, das sind wir inzwischen in Magdeburg auch gut genug aufgestellt. Ich habe es ja gerade gesagt, finanziell müssen wir uns hier gar keine Sorgen machen. Hier wird finanziell sehr, sehr gut gearbeitet. Also hier macht man überhaupt keinen Blödsinn. Da hat man seit 2012 eine sehr, sehr grundsolide, sehr, sehr gute Arbeit geleistet. Man muss sich vorstellen, wir sind aus der 4. Liga gekommen und haben uns in der 3. Liga entschuldet und sind seitdem schuldenfrei. Das schaffen einige nicht mal in der 1. Bundesliga. Und das kann man gar nicht hoch genug aufhängen. Und von daher glaube ich, wir würden uns das so nicht passieren, weil wir einfach auf vielen Ebenen einfach sehr, sehr gesund sind. Außer eben dieses Thema Infrastruktur, Trainingsbedingungen etc., wo eine Menge getan werden muss. Das ist Fakt. Und das schiebt man ja jetzt auch an. Und da passiert jetzt auch in den nächsten anderthalb Jahren was. Aber wenn man natürlich diese Gelder aus der Bundesliga dann haben kann, ich meine, man hat es jetzt bei Kiel gesehen, die sind aufgestiegen. Erstmalig Bundesliga 31 Millionen Euro, nur TV-Gelder. Da reden wir noch nicht von Sponsoren-Geldern, die dazukommen, noch nicht von Zuschauereinnahmen, die dazukommen. Nur dadurch, das wären bei uns 22 Millionen mehr, als wir sie jetzt haben. Und ja, das sind einfach Gelder.
Du musst halt dann gegenüber den eigenen Fans halt standfest bleiben, weil der Ruf hier in Paderborn zumindest damals war, warum wird das Geld jetzt nicht in Spieler investiert, dass man auf jeden Fall versucht, die Klasse zu halten. Und man hat damals mit Steffen Baumgart das ja nicht getan. Man hat quasi niemanden geholt, also keinen für Ablöse oder irgendwas. Man hat tatsächlich das Geld ganz konsequent in die Infrastruktur gestickt. Das hat natürlich auch einige Kritiker auf den Plan gerufen, aber damit muss man dann leben als Verein.
Aber da nehme ich eh so eine generelle Vernunft oder eine Einkette der Vernunft wahr, wenn ich mir die letzten Jahre angucke. Also Kiel und St. Pauli würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass die Unsum in Spieler investiert hätten. Bei Fürth war das vor ein paar Jahren so, dass der Kader sogar schlechter geworden ist als besser, weil damals Verträge ausliefen und die Spieler sich so empfohlen haben, dass sie dann woanders unterschrieben haben. Und dann hat man auch nicht gesagt, dann jetzt erst recht. Und wie du sagst, Thomas, anscheinend, wir haben ja auch schon in der Hinrunde geredet, auch ein bisschen da, länger über die Gremien und so weiter. Da hatte man schon das Gefühl, dass du dir sehr den Eindruck vermittelt hast, dass vernünftige Leute am Werk sind.
Ja, so.
Und sollte der Aufstieg nicht gelingen, würde der FCM immerhin in das 4. Zweitliga-Jahr in Folge gehen. Wäre das auch ein Erfolg?
Ja, absolut.
Kevin hat es schon gesagt, wenn man guckt, wo wir herkommen. Wir sind 2015 das erste Mal im gesamtdeutschen Profifußball überhaupt aufgetaucht. Wenn man guckt, das ist zehn Jahre her und was wir in den letzten zehn Jahren für die Entwicklung genommen haben, das ist, glaube ich, kann man schon von beeindruckend sprechen, ohne da jetzt große Arroganz kriegen zu wollen. Aber das ist, glaube ich, schon beeindruckend, was man hier in den letzten zehn Jahren geleistet hat. Und wenn man da auch bedenkt, dass da ja auch ein Zweitliga-Abstieg schon dabei war und dann auch ein fast Drittliga-Abstieg, den man dann noch abwenden konnte, als man dann Christian Titz geholt hat. Und die Entwicklung seitdem ist ja auch wieder auf eine Art und Weise passiert. Das ist ja schon– ist einfach geil. Und da wird niemand böse sein in der nächsten Saison, wenn der 1. FC Magdeburg nächstes Jahr wieder in der zweiten Liga spielt. Ganz im Gegenteil. Also, wie gesagt, jeder Bundesliga-Abstieg wäre super und sollte man auch dann machen wollen, wenn man diese Möglichkeit bekommt. Aber wir sind noch in einer Situation, wo jedes zweite Jahr für uns auch ein Geschenk ist.
Ja, muss man auch sagen. Ich mag immer das Wort Ostverein nicht gerne, aber in dem Fall einfach, um es mal klarzustellen, ist für mich so der erste Ostverein, der halt auch wirtschaftlich wirklich auf gesunden Füßen steht und wo man das Gefühl hat, die könnten sich jetzt dauerhaft etablieren, endlich. Also das ist ja vielen anderen Clubs nicht gelungen. Dresden, wenn du siehst, immer hoch runter, hoch runter, ganz runter. Rostock, das Gleiche gibt. Also gut, Union Berlin bzw. die Berliner Clubs hast du da noch drin, aber ja.
Das ist ein anderes Konstrukt, ohne jetzt da zu sagen, so weit das Union Berlin instabil ist wirtschaftlich, das wäre nicht der Fall und auch die tun ja gerade richtige Dinge.
Leipzig hat auch einen anderen Hintergrund, aber von den normal wirtschaftenden Vereinen, sag ich mal so.
Exakt. In Union muss man auch sagen, hatte auch viele Jahre und auch eben in den 20er Jahren einen Investor im Rücken, der eben nicht so lautstark aufgetreten ist und dann ist das ja auch an dem Sinne okay, aber es ist Teil der Geschichte und das ist eben anders als bei Magdeburg.
Und da ziehe ich meinen Hut vor dem FCM, das ist wirklich eine richtig tolle Entwicklung. Da passt das alles zusammen. Fan-Kultur, diese Stimmung in dem Stadion ist echt immer noch phänomenal, jedes Mal, wenn ich das mitbekomme. Und wenn man so ein Selbstverständnis hat, dass man auch dankbar ist und ich finde das Wort Demut immer schwierig, weil das immer so künstlich klingt. Aber wenn man das hat, einfach diese Denke, dass es cool ist, in der 2. Liga zu spielen, dass es einfach ein Sahnehäubchen jetzt schon ist, dann kommt man da auch weiter. Also da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass Magdeburg da dauerhaft auch sich etablieren kann und dann auch immer wieder oben anklopfen wird.
Wo will sich denn der Klub mittelfristig etablieren? Also wenn man jetzt sagt, Magdeburg in fünf Jahren, wo siehst du den Klub da?
Wir reden ja immer noch von Profifußball und ich glaube schon, dass die Verantwortlichen im Verein und auch die Spieler, die man holt, auch die wollen natürlich so hoch wie möglich spielen. Ich glaube, sonst hätten sie ihren Beruf verfehlt. Und ich denke schon, dass man auch hier in Magdeburg mittelfristig natürlich, so wie Kevin gerade gesagt hat, in die Situation kommen möchte, wo man einfach ein sehr guter etablierter Zweidickes ist. Ich glaube, das ist aus Paderborn von dann, man will immer zu den ersten 32 Vereinen in Deutschland gehören, war, glaube ich, mal so eine Aussage, ich weiß nicht, ob es Paderborn war oder irgendein anderer Club.
Man hört das oft zu Top 25.
Ja, genau. Und wenn man das schafft, in den nächsten Jahren dahin zu kommen, dass man in der zweiten Liga immer einstellig, was den Tabellenplatz angeht, ist, in den nächsten 3, 4, 5 Jahren. Ich glaube, das wäre für uns schon ein großer Erfolg. Und wenn man es dann schafft, dann auch mal oben anzuklopfen, das wird man hier in Magdeburg sicherlich auch wollen. Das sieht man ja auch daran, wie man im Umfeld jetzt agiert. Man schiebt jetzt Dinge an, was das Trainingszentrum angeht. Man schiebt Dinge an, was um die U23 wird, mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit in die Regionalliga aufsteigen. Wir haben jetzt sieben Punkte Vorsprung in der Oberliga. Das sieht auch danach aus, dass sie hochgehen. Auch da passiert etwas. Mal gucken, wie das dann trägt, weil die Regionalliga ist schon ein anderes Brett als die Oberliga. Aber grundsätzlich passiert hier gerade eine Menge, auch im sportlichen Bereich. Ich denke schon, dass da der Anspruch auch mittelfristig sein wird und in meiner Meinung auch ein Stück weit sein muss, dass man auch mal oben anklopfen möchte. Absolut.
Und glaubst du, dass Christian Titz diesem Weg noch viele Jahre mitgehen wird? Oder glaubst du, dass da auch– weil Feinde sind jetzt nicht blind. Die sehen, dass er einen wirklich herausragenden Teil zu den letzten Jahren des 1. FC Magdeburg beigetragen hat. Glaubst du, dass er sich von größeren Clubs locken lassen könnte mit anderen Möglichkeiten, wo er seinen Fußball vielleicht noch spektakulärer spielen lassen könnte? Oder ist er mittlerweile so mit diesem Verein verwachsen, dass er sagt, da müsste schon viel kommen, dass ich sage, dass ich das Projekt hier verlasse?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, grundsätzlich, wenn dann ein Engländer kommt und sagt aus der 1. oder 2. Liga und sagt, Mensch, Herr Titz, hätten Sie nicht Lust, hier zu trainieren? Ich glaube, das wird dann schon schwierig, auch rein finanziell, was man ihm auch überhaupt nicht verdenken könnte. Also ich glaube, da dann auch finanziell mitzuhalten, würde schon sehr, sehr schwierig werden. Ich tue mich auch immer schwer, so ein bisschen von Dankbarkeit zu sprechen, aber man hat ja auch gesehen, wir haben Christian Titz auch so ein bisschen aus der Versenkung wieder rausgeholt. Er war ja damals in Essen entlassen worden. Dann war er jetzt nichts mehr, dann kam er ja zu uns und hat sich hier, ich sage mal, so ein bisschen auf die Landkarte trainiert. Ich schätze Christian Titz eigentlich schon so ein, dass er eben auch weiß, was er hier in Magdeburg hat. Er kann hier in Ruhe arbeiten. Ich habe das ja in der Hinrunde auch bei euch schon gesagt. Selbst letzte Saison, wo es in der Rückrunde überhaupt nicht lief, wo wir davon zwölf Spielen, glaube ich, nur eins gewonnen haben, war hier im Verein absolute Ruhe. Keiner ist im Umfeld, auch nur im Ansatz auf die Idee gekommen, den Trainern Frage zu stellen. Ich glaube, das ist für Christian Titz vielleicht auch nach den Erfahrungen, die er eben auch in Essen gemacht hat oder auch in Hamburg damals, vielleicht auch etwas, wo er sagt, Mensch, das schätze ich hier schon in Magdeburg, dass hier Ruhe ist, dass ich meine Arbeit machen kann und dass hier nicht nach drei Spielen mein komplettes Konstrukt in Frage gestellt wird. Von daher kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass es hier noch ein paar Jahre gehen wird.
Ich merke schon, ich erkenne hier viele Parallelen zwischen Magdeburg und Paderborn. Das ist ganz fantastisch und lässt mich ja zu perfekt überleiten an der Stelle. Es ist ein Traum. Wir leben diese Freundschaft jetzt einfach im Rasenfunk auch aus. Kevin, freundlich fangen wir aber nicht an, wir müssen über die letzten drei Partien reden. Die wurden leider allesamt verloren. Also man hat gegen Köln knapp verloren, gegen Lautern knapp verloren und jetzt gegen Düsseldorf knapp verloren. Dazu ja auch noch gegen die direkte Konkurrenz, was dann immer so ein bisschen doppelt wehtut. Kannst du uns nochmal durch die letzten Auftritte führen und erklären, warum Paderborn jedes Mal den Kürzeren gezogen hat?
Ich versuche das mal kurz und knapp zu machen. Ja, die Spiele waren allesamt gut bis sehr gut von uns gespielt. Eigentlich in jedem Spiel klar überlegen in einer Mannschaft gewesen, die in fast allen Belangen überlegen, also auch statistisch, wenn du da reinguckst in die Werte. Sowohl gegen Düsseldorf als auch gegen Braunschweig. Gegen Köln war es teilweise natürlich nicht so deutlich, aber gegen Braunschweig und vor allem in der ersten Halbzeit gegen Braunschweig und gegen Düsseldorf eigentlich übers gesamte Spiel war das schon dominant, was den Spielstil anging, was aber natürlich unser Problem die ganze Säuber ist und das hat sich hier ausgeschlagen ist, dass wir sehr viele Chancen brauchen, um Tore zu machen. Wir haben keinen klaren Goal-Getter in der Mannschaft, auch wenn jetzt Grimaldi zum Beispiel in der Rückrunde sehr gehypt wird, weil er einfach cooler Typ ist, kommt rein und macht eine Bude, der wirbelt die ganze Mannschaft durcheinander. Er ist ein toller Stürmer, der auch jetzt verlängert hat, ist natürlich schon auch älter, aber du hast halt sonst drum herum– Bilbia hat in der Hinrunde in den ersten sechs Spielen gefühlt sechs Tore geschossen, danach ein halbes Jahr gar nicht mehr und hat jetzt, glaube ich, acht– oder ist auch nicht so ganz wichtig, aber hat er auf jeden Fall nicht weiter getroffen. Du hast keinen klaren Goalgetter. Was jetzt passiert ist in diesen Spielen, wir haben zehn Gegentore kassiert. In drei Spielen, in vier Spielen mit Casas Lautern, das haben wir noch gewonnen gegen Lautern, auch da haben wir drei nur geführt, haben dann das 3-3 kassiert und haben es dann trotzdem noch mal gewinnen können.
Das ist ein geiles Spiel.
Ja, für ein Fußball-Fan.
Neutral gesehen war es geil.
Auf jeden Fall, das stimmt. Auch als Fan des SCP, wenn du das dann gewinnst, ist das natürlich auch ein Hammer-Spiel. Aber drei Gegentore, gegen Köln zwei Gegentore, gegen Braunschweig, was haben wir jetzt? Fünf? Auch drei Gegentore, ne? Und jetzt zwei Gegentore. Vorher in 26 oder 25 Saison-Spielen hatten wir 29 Gegentore insgesamt. Das ist also schon krass. Also das ist das, was so auffällt in diesen drei Spielen. Das heißt, was ist passiert? Wir haben unsere komplette Innenverteidigung fast verloren. Brackelmann, Verletz Güze, auf einmal nach diesem Köln-Spiel ins zentrale Mittelfeld vorgezogen worden. Ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum. Der quasi der Shooting-Star in dieser Zweitliga so in der Innenverteidigung ist und ein Scheller, der von St. Pauli gekommen ist vor der Saison, eine super Rolle gespielt hat, auf einmal zentral als Innenverteidiger gestellt, hat da immer wieder jetzt Probleme gehabt. Für mich ein komisches, gefühlt hausgemachtes Problem. Natürlich auch dem schuldet, dass auch Meelen sich verletzt hat, Klaas sich verletzt hat. Das heißt, unser Defensivverbund ist irgendwie auseinandergerissen worden. Und das hat die Mannschaft nicht kompensieren können. Wir kriegen total bescheuerte Gegentore.
Ich wollte mich gerade fragen, also zum einen nochmal, du hast vorhin richtig gesagt, das eine Spiel war jetzt nicht Kaisersottern, sondern Braunschweig. Das muss man natürlich nochmal sagen. Ich hatte das in der Aufzählung falsch gesagt. Gegen Braunschweig hatte man verloren. Aber ist das jetzt gerade ein strukturelles Problem, dass man sagt, man verteidigt im Verbund nicht mehr so kompakt oder Ähnliches? Oder sind es individuelle Patzer?
Individuelle Patzer, glaube ich schon. Weil, wenn du das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf siehst, wie gesagt, ich habe es eigentlich schon gesagt, wir haben die ersten 40 Minuten quasi keinen Torschuss zugelassen. Also grundsätzlich hat der Defensivverbund ja schon funktioniert, aber die Spieler sind teilweise dann, weil sie auf ungewohnter Position vielleicht spielen und ich weiß es nicht, oder das einfach auch schwierig ist, über 90 Minuten auf Zweitliganiveau das dann immer wegzuverteilen, du musst zu dem Zeitpunkt gegen Düsseldorf 2 oder 3-0 führen, ist einfach so. Dann ist der Ofen aus, außer es kommt wieder immer dran auf den 3-3, aber in der Regel ist dann das Ding aus und du fängst hier in wohl 1, wo der Ball über die rechte Seite kommt, das wird quasi nicht attackiert. In der Mitte steht der Verteidiger zwischen zwei Angreifern und ist dann halt nicht parat. Die legen sich den einfach einmal in die Mitte ab und der Schmidt macht das Tor ungehindert und nicht attackiert. Solche Tore fangen wir uns halt momentan.
Das ist dann noch der Elfmeter, der war ja auch selten. Einfach blöd, ja. Einfach dämlich. Ohne Not geht er da hin. Der Ball wäre ja sowieso reingegangen, aber trotzdem war der Elfmeter einfach auch in Umstellung. Sau doof, ja.
Aber ist das dann eine Kopfsache oder eine Qualitätsfrage?
Wenn wir Lukas Kwasniok folgen würden im Winter, im Dezember, wäre es eine Qualitätsfrage.
Das hat er deutlich gemacht, ja.
Jetzt haben wir ja aber nachgebessert im Winter, wobei die Spieler, die da gekommen sind, ja eigentlich auch jetzt gerade wieder nicht spielen.
Aber wollen wir da kurz über Manuel Riemann reden?
Können wir gleich gerne machen, ja. Also ich glaube, ich glaube nicht, dass das eine Struktur ist. Ich glaube, es ist eine Kopfsache. Ich habe bei Thomas vorhin einmal aufgehörigt, als er sagte, Drucksituation. Wir waren auf einmal nur noch zwei Punkte oder drei Punkte hinter dem HSV. Das wird das, wo Thomas meinte, glaube ich, so Geheimfavorit, SCP, haben den HSV besiegt gehabt, haben gegen Kaiserslautern gewonnen gehabt und dann kam der FC Köln und den hatten, gegen die haben wir geführt quasi und hatten, also im Stadion war so, krass, jetzt auch noch Köln, gegen Köln in Führung, jetzt, wer soll uns noch stoppen? Und dann fängst du dir so dieses dämliche 1 zu 1, wo der Ball an den Hinterkopf knallt und du denkst, das gibt es doch nicht, jetzt kommt wieder der ehemalige Bundesligis und hat wieder Duseln und keine Ahnung. Und dann halt das Braunschweig-Spiel hat, glaube ich, so, weiß ich nicht. Also ich glaube, es ist so eine Mischung Druck dabei, die ganze Situation auch, dass immer über den Trainer gesprochen wird auch. Das ist auch eine Begleiterscheidung.
Über das Thema werden wir auf jeden Fall noch reden. Aber du sagst, einer der 9 im Winter war Manuel Riemann. Das ist ja schon eine besondere Personalie, dass so ein alter Torhüter, der ist eigentlich schon festgewachsen im Bochum, der kann ja körperlich gar nicht mehr weg. Dass der dann noch mal in Paderborn aufschlägt. Wie nimmst du ihn denn bislang wahr, individuell und auch in der Wirkung auf die Mannschaft? Weil das war sicherlich auch ein Grund, warum man ihn geholt hat. Und es kommt ja noch dazu, dass Kwasniok vorher gefühlt verbal jeden Torhüter in Paderborn einmal rasiert hatte. Also da war ja auch eine gewisse Fallhöhe dann da für den neuen.
Ja, hat ja quasi zwei Torhüterkarrieren beendet. Irgendwie ist das Profi-Niveau.
Und da vorher gefühlt auch schon mit Hut, hat er den nicht auch einmal niedergemacht. Also irgendwas ist da, liegt da tiefer begraben.
Aber was ich da ganz gern finde, Kevin, vielleicht kannst du das würde mich auch mal interessieren. Riemann ist ja jetzt auch, ich sag mal so Torhüter älterer Generation. Ihr habt ja die anderen beiden, die ihr da im Tor hattet, waren ja eher jünger. Ich finde schon, dass man das auch Kwasniok vielleicht jetzt gesehen hat, okay, es ist zwar schön, gute Mitspieler eine Torhüter zu haben, mit guter Fuß, etc., pp., aber letzten Endes sollten Torhüter dann doch erstmal die Grundlagen im Tor beherrschen und ich glaube...
Im Moment hast du mal Manuel Riemanns Schuss im letzten Spiel gesehen, der Mann, der keine Probleme hat, vorne reingesteckt.
Okay, ja, aber ich glaube, grundsätzlich ist es schon so... Ich habe das Gefühl, dass man in Paderborn jetzt erst mal wieder ein Torhüter im Tor hat, wo man weiß, okay, der beherrscht die grundlegenden Torhüter-Dinge erstmal sehr gut und das andere kommt dann vielleicht noch dazu. Aber ist das vielleicht auch ein Punkt, warum man gesagt hat, wir brauchen erstmal wieder ein Torhüter, der erstmal im Torhüterspiel grundsätzlich seine Stärken hat und weniger im Spiel aufbaut?
Viele Fragen auf einmal.
Ich glaube, man hat einfach das Problem in Paderborn, dass man immer gerne ein Torhüter hat, der einerseits mit der Mannschaft mitspielt und zwar gut mitspielt, der aber auch die alten Tugenden, was du gerade meinst, also Schlafraumbeherrschung im richtigen Moment rauskommt, die Mannschaft die Verteidigung stellen und also das Ganze. Davon hatten wir jetzt ja verschiedene Torhüter. Bei Schubert ist es so, dem sagt man auch, das ist ein Keeper im klassischen Stile, aber aus dem Tor raus brauchst du den nicht schicken. Und bei unserem niederländischen Freund, der uns ja dann im Winter verlassen hat, Pelle Boving, war das eher das Gegenteil. Der ist ja Vogelwelt rausgeflattert aus dem Tor und rumgerannt über das ganze Spielfeld. Und hat das aber auch gut gemacht, hat auch Spitzenreflexe, aber hat halt einfach das Problem gehabt, dass er immer wieder Bock drin hat. Ja, ich glaube, man wollte auch jetzt einfach mal einen gesetzten, erfahrenen Keeper haben, der Ruhe bewahrt, der schon alles gesehen hat. Von Relegation über Aufstieg, Abstieg, Niederlagen, Siege.
Du musstest gerade ein bisschen schmunzeln, als du bei Manuel Riemann gesagt hast, der die Ruhe bewahrt.
Ja, das ist sein Ding. Er tut es schon, glaube ich. Er strahlt auf die Mannschaft irgendwie zumindest einen beruhigenden Faktor aus, weil sie ihn einfach alle kennen aus dem Fernsehen und so. Die ganzen jungen Spieler kennen den halt auch schon seit gefühlt 20 Jahren. Und das ist einfach, glaube ich, so eine gewisse Respektsnummer dann auch. Das ist einfach ein erfahrener Keeper. Wie gesagt, Bundesliga auch schon gespielt. Ist was Besonderes. Und er hat einfach, glaube ich, auch dann schon auch die Gabe, seine Vorderleute unaufgeregt zu stellen. Also ist er tatsächlich gar nicht so oft so, dass ich hätte erwartet, er würde viel mehr schreien oder irgendwie so. Aber es fällt mir bei ihm gar nicht so auf. Mir fällt auf, dass er nie eine Mütze aufsetzt, um gegen die Sonne blicken zu können.
Manuel Riemann ist stärker als die Sonne.
Ja, absolut. Weiß ich nicht. Also ist, glaube ich, schon eine sinnvolle Verpflichtung. Und jetzt ist es aber, glaube ich, auch ein Übergangsnummer. Er ist ja, wie du sagst, auch schon älter. Ob er jetzt über den Sommer hinaus bleibt, keine Ahnung, kommt jetzt auch sicherlich drauf an, was im Sommer sich sonst noch so tut in Paderborn.
Kwasniok selbst, über den wir gleich noch mal gesondert reden wollen, aber auch Spieler wie jetzt Ilyas Ansar oder Aron Zehnta, zig Personen vom SCP, werden ja aktuell auch bei anderen Vereinen gehandelt. Hast du das Gefühl, diese Situation raubt aktuell womöglich auch den entscheidenden Fokus, sowohl dann hinten, was die defensiven Patzer angeht, als auch vorne die Effizienz?
Erstmal sind diese Spieler glaube ich tatsächlich alle weg im Sommer, wenn wir nicht aufsteigen. Das ist glaube ich so sicher wie das Arm in der Kirche. Und dann fangen wir halt beim SCP wieder von null an nicht, aber Thomas weiß es auch selbst, so eine Mannschaft, und du weißt es natürlich auch, so eine Mannschaft aufzubauen, wie sie jetzt spielt auf dem Niveau, dauert halt 3, 4 Jahre. Das hast du bei Darmstadt gesehen, bei Heidenheim, die haben alle länger zusammengespielt. Wenn du jetzt quasi das auf dem Peak, wo die Mannschaft gerade ist, nicht schaffst, hochzugehen, dann sind die weg. Wenn du nach einem Zehntag fragst oder ein Zehntag sprichst, dann ist das für mich ein Spieler. Sorry, der wird sogar im Falle eines Aufstiegs weg sein. Weil das für mich mit Abstand einer der besten Spieler auf der linken Bahn in dieser Liga ist. Es ist unfassbar, wie gut der ist, wie schnell der ist. Und der ist 20, also der ist 20. Ich will gar nicht wissen, was der in einem Umfeld noch aus sich herausholen kann. Oder was man aus ihm noch herausholen kann in einem Umfeld, wo noch stärkere Spieler einfach sind, die ihn nochmal anders mitnehmen können. Da bin ich gespannt. Jetzt habe ich deine eigentliche Frage, aber glaube ich, vergessen gerade.
Ja, wenn diese Spieler gefühlt schon weg sind, ob das nicht in der aktuellen Situation schmerzt, wenn sie dann nicht den ganzen Fokus haben, weil sie wissen...
Ich glaube, die haben schon den Fokus. Ich glaube, das wird jetzt gerade schwierig, weil während wir gerade sprechen, hat der SCP ja gerade begangen, gegeben, dass der Trainer den Verein verlassen wird im Sommer. Ist jetzt gerade offiziell gepostet worden und per Pressemitteilung versendet worden.
Guck mal, ist das nicht schön. Kein Podcast-Tuch. Wir können gleich live brühwarm drüber reden.
Absolut. Also wir haben vor der Sendung, um die Leute hier alle zu informieren, haben noch darüber gesprochen, weil ich habe schon ein paar Vögel zwitschern heute tagsüber. Und wir haben überlegt, wie wir das jetzt machen können, weil es halt nicht offiziell war. Und jetzt ist es aber offiziell. Das heißt, man geht da wirklich schmerzfrei den Weg, dass der Trainer auch geht. Das war für mich auch klar. Das ist wenig überraschend für mich. Wie ich aber aus der Mannschaft so gehört habe, war das für nicht alle Spieler so klar. Und da schließt jetzt deine Frage den Kreis zu deiner Frage. Wird es tatsächlich interessant, ob die Mannschaft das so umwandelt, dass sie daraus jetzt einen Push nochmal kriegt, um zu sagen, wir wollen jetzt zusammen das Ding schaffen, und dann haben wir was erreicht. Oder ob das jetzt eher so ist, oh nee, wenn der Trainer jetzt geht, gucke ich mir auch schon mal um, wo ich hingehe. Ich schätze ein, dass es nicht für den Aufstieg reichen wird.
Ja, bevor wir zu einem… Genau, also gut, da hast du es mir eigentlich quasi vorweg genommen. Wenn wir da auf das Restprogramm nämlich schauen, auch das ist ja jetzt gar nicht mal so einfach. Also Nürnberg, Elbersberg, Schalke, dann das Magdeburg-Spiel und dann KSC. Also Schalke, KSC ist dieselbe Nummer, wie wir vorhin drüber geredet haben. Für die wird es um nichts mehr gehen zu dem Zeitpunkt. Das kann natürlich dankbar sein. Aber Nürnberg, Elbersberg und Magdeburg, das dürften ziemlich heiße Spiele werden. Und jetzt mit drei Niederlagen im Rücken. Du hast gesagt, die Leistungen haben gestimmt. Aber es ist ja oftmals dann so, dass die Leistungen sich irgendwie in den Ergebnissen anpassen, weil dann auch manchmal so ein bisschen der Glaube fehlt, die Spiele noch zu ziehen. Also liegst du gegen Nürnberg wieder hinten aus einer doofen Situation, obwohl du sonst leistungsrechtlich nichts falsch gemacht hast, dann wird es ja wieder schöner.
Vielleicht habe ich auch gerade zuvor schnell geurteilt. Also die Mannschaft hat ja schon immer diesen Spirit. Nicht umsonst sind wir die Mannschaft mit den meisten Toren in der letzten Viertelstunde. Ich glaube, es sind wir. Oder der HSV ist es, einer von beiden. Und das war auch gegen Düsseldorf so. Hätten wir noch 10 Minuten mehr gehabt, hätten wir es, glaube ich, sogar noch gedreht in Unterzahl. Die hat den absoluten Spirit und ich spüre da auch den Willen, dass sie das schaffen wollen. Sie scheitern einfach an sich selbst teilweise. An den Erwartungshaltungen, an dem sie überhastet agieren und dann diese Flüchtigkeitsfehler begehen. Ich glaube, sie haben absolut das Potenzial, auch in diesen Spielen zu bestehen. In Nürnberg ist jetzt auch nicht unser liebster Gegner, aber das sehe ich schon realistisch. Elversberg ist hart. Also Elversberg ist sehr, sehr hart. Die haben ja in Anführungsstrichen gar nichts zu verlieren. Das sagt man immer so leicht. Die haben natürlich auch Druck irgendwo, aber eigentlich von den Kandidaten, die gerade da oben drin sind, sind es quasi die, wo es keiner gedacht hätte. Magdeburg, so haben wir ja schon gesagt, schwierig. Und Schalke, die haben wir auch noch nicht so viele Punkte geholt in der Fans-Historie. Also, weiß ich nicht. Es gäb leichtere Programme, aber eigentlich ist es auch immer gut, weil wenn wir leichte Gegner haben, patzen wir auch oft. Also, ich glaube, die Mannschaft braucht sich gar nicht verstecken. Vom Können her, von der Spielanlage her, können die alle die Spiele gewinnen. Aber, ja, wie du sagst, klar, wenn man irgendwann das Vierte verliert oder so, dann ist natürlich auch der Abstand irgendwann zu groß. Aber es sind zwei Punkte nur, ne?
Ja, voll. Aber geht es nach Lukas Kwasniok, hat man dann am letzten Spieltag im Wildpark ein Finale, in dem er für ihn natürlich… Und es wird dann auch sein Finale, wie wir jetzt dann offiziell besprechen können.
Und er kommt ja auch aus der Gegend. Er kommt ja auch noch. Da hat er beim Cast hier auch schon gearbeitet. Also, das wäre für ihn natürlich dreifach toll.
In den letzten Wochen, ja, fast Monaten, muss man sagen, verging er gefühlt keinen Tag ohne neues Gerücht zu seiner Zukunft. Jetzt ist es dann eben spruchreif. Er hat auf der einen Seite natürlich auch immer wieder ein Feuer ausgestrahlt, weil ich glaube, ohne Feuer gibt es auch kein Lukas Kwasniok. Und gleichzeitig immer wieder gehadert, auch öffentlich mit den limitierten Möglichkeiten des SCP. Und dass man da nicht über eine gewisse Schwelle kommt und man immer im Optimum kratzt, aber das Optimum halt limitiert ist. Wie blickst du denn jetzt auf seine Amtszeit dann zurück, sportlich wie menschlich?
Er ist ja ein streitbarer Mensch. Je nachdem, was für Ansichten man so hat im Leben, wie man so durchs Leben geht, weiß jetzt wahrscheinlich auch jeder, worauf ich anspiele. Also sei es die Impfnummer, sei es sein Ausflug nach Mallorca oder halt eben die öffentliche Deklassierung seiner Keeper oder überhaupt der ganzen Mannschaft. Da kann man immer von halten, was man möchte. Da soll sich jeder bitte sein eigenes Bild auch zu bilden und auch seine Meinung. Trotz alledem hat er es immer geschafft, im Verein zu bleiben. Also ich glaube, jeder hat immer wieder gedacht, also spätestens nach der Mallorca-Nummer, dass dann jetzt auf Schicht im Schacht ist. Dem war aber nicht so. Der Verein hat ihm echt immer den Rücken gestärkt. Und das hat er, glaube ich, tatsächlich auch ohne, dass das irgendwie nur so herausgesagt hat, dem Verein, glaube ich, bis heute sehr dankbar. Oder ist dem Verein sehr dankbar und hat den Verein wirklich, glaube ich, auch lieben gelernt. Das sagen Menschen ja oft auch in der Euphorie so, aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass der seine Mannschaft sehr, sehr gern hat und sehr, sehr gern mit der arbeitet. Und das im Dezember war einfach eine Frustnummer. Also wenn man so ein bisschen hinter den Kulissen weiß, dass im Jahr, als der VfB Stuttgart, bevor die Hoeneß geholt haben, eigentlich Wohlgemut ihn haben wollte, der SCP ihn nicht freigegeben hat, bevor der HSV Steffen Baumgart geholt hatte, wollten sie ihn auch haben, hat der SCP ihn nicht freigegeben. Dann hat er seinen Vertrag verlängert und, wie man so hört, hat er dann auch seine Ausstiegsklausel mitverkauft. Das heißt, er hat auch ganz gut wahrscheinlich was für bekommen. Und dann wollte er HSV ihn jetzt wieder haben. Klimaldarmen hat Lukas Kwasniok hier so 25.000 bis 30.000 verdient pro Monat, würde ich schätzen. Und der HSV hat ihm halt 120.000 ungefähr angeboten. Und wenn man dann natürlich überlegt, wo Lukas Kwasniok herkommt, auch nicht aus einem superreichen Elternhaus und es ihm auch nicht alles in den Schoß gefallen hat, hat wirklich viel gearbeitet dafür, dass er da ist, wo er jetzt ist. Hat auch viele Jobs gemacht, war als er beim KSC oder wo es war, neben da noch Dachdecker und so weiter. Also hat, ne, es ihm ist nicht alles zugefallen. Dann kann man es aus der Sicht natürlich vielleicht auch verstehen, dass ihn das persönlich natürlich fertig gemacht hat, weil das natürlich, da hat das große Geld gewunken. Das war quasi die Absicherung für weitere Lebensjahre. Sportlich gesehen war es natürlich schwierig, sag ich mal. Du stehst Ende November auf Platz 1 der 2. Liga und verlierst dann im Dezember alles. Und hast einen Trainer, der noch draufhaut und drauftritt und quasi öffentlich die Mannschaft, ja, demontiert vielleicht nicht, aber zumindest Teile der Mannschaft, wie gesagt, die beiden Keeper. Ich habe Respekt vor Schubert, dass er noch im Verein geblieben ist, sag ich mal so. Die Picker war hart.
Die war hart.
Ja, also das war schon krass. Wie blicke ich aber insgesamt zurück? Ein Top-Trainer, also vom Können her, ist für mich der beste Trainer der 2. Liga, was das In-Game-Coaching angeht. In der 1. Liga kann ich es nicht vergleichen, weil ich das zu sehen zu wenig verfolge. In der 2. Liga ist es der Trainer, der am besten in meiner Ansicht nach im Spiel, während des Spiels auf Situationen reagiert hat, in dieser und auch in den letzten Jahren. Er hat ein gutes Verständnis auf, wie man eine Mannschaft mitnehmen kann und halt auch einen großen Ehrgeiz. Und den hat er in die Mannschaft reingebracht. Er hat jetzt wirklich auch mit Ruhe 3 bis 4 Jahre gearbeitet und sich nicht beirren lassen, von einem Platz 7 oder von einem Platz 8 oder sowas, sondern dann sukzessive. Auch der Verein muss mir auch einen Lob zollen. Also waren zufrieden, haben dann auch mal tief gestapelt. Ja, wir wollen uns jeden so einen Platz verbessern und solche Sachen. Ja, und hat einfach ein Händchen, auch junge Spieler zu integrieren. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das bei ihm dann für den großen Wurf reicht. Aber ich glaube schon, dass er ein Bundesligatrainer sein kann. Er ist der erste Bundesliga-Major. Ein enormes Potenzial und der Verein, das muss man ja auch mal sagen, in solche Fußstaffen zu treten, die Steffen Baumgart hier hinterlassen hat.
Das muss man sagen.
Dann auch es zu schaffen, hier vier Jahre Trainer zu bleiben, ist halt auch krass. Also SCP hat in den letzten, wann ist Baumgart gekommen? 2014, 2015?
Ende 2013, 2014, 14, 15. Nee, stimmt nicht. Es war später. Wir sind aufgestiegen vor der Saison 2017, 2018 sind wir aufgestiegen und wir sind dann der Bundesliga hochmarschiert.
Wir hatten auf jeden Fall zwei Trainer in den letzten 8-10 Jahren. Krass, also SC Freiburg hat sowas. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Thomas…
In den Baumdaten kam 2017.
2017, siehst du, Thomas weiß das besser als ich.
Ich sag, ey, Podcast-Beinschaft, mal gucken, wie viel Beweis und Beweis.
Aber irre, selbst das von 2017 bis 2025 zwei Trainer, das ist schon… Und das spricht für Lukas Kwasniok definitiv, also sportlich, dass ich da wenig an drunten rankomme. Das, was er noch lernen muss, ist einfach in bestimmten Situationen, die Mannschaft nicht so schwach zu reden. Das ist über die Jahre immer wieder ein Problem gewesen, wenn man oben stand, dann haben er es und auch Benny Weber, jetzt der sportliche Vorstand, immer wieder gerne mal gemacht, dass man gesagt hat, ja, also das ist gerade nicht das, was die Mannschaft… Also das ist gerade nicht unser Niveau da oben. Also das ist nicht unser Können, unser Potential ist tiefer. Unsere Mannschaft ist überperformed. Das muss man die Füße stillhalten. Und immer dann kam auch der Knick. Das ist total krass. Immer wenn man das zu gemacht hat, es war im November, Ende November auch, als man auf Platz 1 stand, dann, ach nee, ach komm, hör mir auf. Frag mich nochmal nach dem 35. Spiel, oder irgendwie so. Ja, ja, genau. Also am besten nächste Saison erst fragen. Und ja, das ist noch so ein Ding. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch echt schwierig, in so einer Situation zu arbeiten, wo du weißt, der Verein hat keine Kohle für Spieler, die schon mal was erlebt haben, irgendwo. Und du musst halt immer wieder anfangen von vorne quasi. Du verlierst einen Schallenberg, du verlierst einen Justwahn, du verlierst einen, äh, hier, wie heißt er, mit M, der nach Freiburg gegangen ist. Guck mal, Muslia, so. Ja, und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt, wenn wir jetzt mal drüber gucken, welche Spieler jetzt gehen werden, sind das meine Ansicht nach Zehnther, Anser, Obermeier, Brackelmann, Castaneda. Und habe ich noch einen vergessen.
Engels vielleicht.
Engels, ja, der war jetzt zu sehr verletzt, das wird noch dauern. Das ist einfach, ja, und dann ist ja quasi die ganze, also die halbe Startelfeck, ne. Und das frustriert dich als Trainer natürlich, das war das, was er, glaube ich, meinte. Der arbeitet so, hat mit der Mannschaft zusammen und scheitert immer dann kurz vor knapp. Und da hat er, der will jetzt einfach was anderes sehen. Soll er auch machen, ist auch gut. Hier wäre über den Sommer auch gar kein, also das hat er sich im Winter kaputt gehauen, die Scherben gehauen, das wäre über den Sommer nicht gegangen. Also mit dem Aufstieg vielleicht noch, ja, okay. Aber dafür hat er jetzt auch einfach zu viele Offerten. Der wird jetzt gefühlt bei jedem Verein gehandelt.
Aber ich glaube, das wird beim SCP, das ist so der Eindruck, den ich hier aus der Entfernung habe, ich glaube seit Krösche hat man in Paderbornen Strukturen aufgebaut, wo man es geschafft hat, so ein Stück weit personenunabhängig zu werden. Wenn man überlegt, was da in den letzten Jahren Krösche weg, Wohlgemut weg, Baumgott weg und das war ja immer so, dass Paderbornen es geschafft hat, trotzdem in ihrer Arbeit weiter konstant zu bleiben, weiter auch bei sich zu bleiben und da finde ich, das ist etwas, das hat man uns in Magdeburg in meiner Meinung noch voraus, dass man es geschafft hat, ein Stück weit personenunabhängig zu sein. Das ist ein ganz großes Pfund in der 2. Liga, dass du eben nicht davon abhängig bist, dass da ein Trainer kommt, von dem machst du dich wieder abhängig, dass der seine Ideen reinbringt, dann schmeißt du den auch von raus, dann stehst du wieder bei Null. Ich glaube, das ist ein Punkt, da hat Paderbornen einigen 2. Ligisten voraus, dass man sagen kann, die sind personenunabhängig, die können da hinsetzen, wen sie wollen, das funktioniert.
Ein paar Erstligisten, ja. Das ist tatsächlich so, das war das, was ich vorhin meinte. Als Kwasniok, als Kwasniok ist, also Markus Kwasniok ist hier, glaube ich, fast jeder dankbar in Paderborn, weil der ist wirklich, also das wirklichen, es klingt jetzt sehr hochtram, das Mastermind, was das angeht. Der hat diesen Verein einfach gelesen, der weiß, wie der Verein funktioniert. Der wusste ganz genau aus seiner Karriere heraus, aus seinem Studium, was er nebenbei hatte, aus seinen Erfahrungen in Leverkusen, was zu tun muss, damit das bei so einem Verein überhaupt irgendwie mit Profi-Fußball funktionieren kann. Und das haben nicht viele andere Feinde. Wenn du siehst, was Krösche jetzt aus Spielern, also was der in Frankfurt für Ablösen erzielt mit Spielern, das ist ja unfassbar.
Und gleichzeitig performt die Mannschaft trotzdem weiter durch. Also nicht so, dass du die 100 Millionen einnimmst und plötzlich bist du elfter, sondern die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder Champions League spielen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wenn die jetzt Elias Ansa tatsächlich holen sollten. Wo der Weg so hinführt von ihm.
Ich würde auch gelesen, Union Berlin soll auch dran sein. Das sind ja noch zwei verschiedene Welten. Mal gucken, wie das ausgeht. Du hast schon ein bisschen darüber geredet. Du glaubst, dass die Mannschaft schon im Sommer ein Stück weit auseinanderfallen könnte oder wird. Bei einem ausbleibenden Aufstieg ja umso mehr wahrscheinlich, weil diese Spieler dann noch mehr das Bedürfnis haben werden, was anderes zu sehen. Aber auch wenn du den Abgesang schon ein bisschen gestartet hast, der Aufstieg ist ja immer noch drin.
Absolut.
Solange Lukas Kwasniok da ist, glaube ich, wird er auch noch dem Höchsten streben, weil das sieht ja im Portfolio nicht so ganz verkehrt aus, mit Paderborn das dann auch geschafft zu haben.
Das stimmt.
Glaubst du denn, dass Paderborn dieses Mal besser absteigen könnte als 14, 15 und 19, 20, als man dann jeweils wieder als 18. runtergegangen ist? Oder ist das einfach die Beste Realität? Du gehst hoch, nimmst wieder was, schürfst ein bisschen was ab, wirtschaftlich und gehst wieder runter.
Ja, da ist der Verein noch nicht. Der Verein hat sich auf jeden Fall weiterentwickelt, hat deutlich mehr Potenziale geschaffen. Aber mir fehlt da die Fantasie. Die Fantasie fehlt mir nicht, aber mir fehlt der realistische, nachhaltige Beweis, dass das klappen könnte. Weil wir haben, glaube ich, 20 oder irgendwas Millionen zur Verfügung. Und wenn es dann die 1. Liga ist, dann sind es vielleicht 35 maximal. Ja, sorry. Da gewinnst du keinen Blumentopf in der 1. Bundesliga. Da kann wieder auf Euphorie-Welle irgendwie, wenn die Mannschaft zusammenbleiben würde, im Fall des Aufstiegs könnte auf der Euphorie-Welle irgendwie geritten werden. Aber du hast ja dann auch einen neuen Trainer. Ja, so dann glaube ich nicht. Also, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Weiß nicht, wie.
Das wäre natürlich irgendwie fast undankbar als neuer Trainer, dass dann schon klar, du dürftest im Bundesliga-Feind trainieren.
Naja, klar.
So etwas ist nie undankbar, aber gleichzeitig, was willst du da gewinnen? Aber ja, das sind Sorgen für die Zukunft. Ich glaube, an der Stelle machen wir die Nummer dann zu. Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir berühmt waren, dann noch über die Kwasniok-Nummer reden konnten und da jetzt nicht so im theoretischen Raum bleiben mussten. Das hilft natürlich total. Dementsprechend zünde ich jetzt schon mal das Intro ab und bedanke mich an der Stelle. Vielen lieben Dank, Thomas Haufe, für deine Zeit nur der FCM-Podcast. Hört rein. Danke. Und zum anderen Kevin Bublitz vom Padercast. Wie immer eine Freude. Dieses Mal durfte ich die Freude teilen. Hat großen Spaß gemacht. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Vielen lieben Dank. Bis dann.
So, dann wie gesagt, Supporters Club und Kontoumständungen nicht vergessen. Wichtig, wichtig.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.